[MUSIC]
In the future, it will not be so odd for
people who are raising children
to have part time jobs,
both of them and that that will
be seen as a normal thing to do.
So, I'm very optimistic
that change will come.
Even if you're not planning to have
a spouse and your own children,
you're still part of a family.
And one of the topics we have,
actually, is elder care.
How are you going to be dealing with
your parents when they get older?
And just about everybody has parents,
so [LAUGH] family writ large.
Your family of origin, your family
nuclear family that you may start or
have already started.
How are you going to balance work and
family in your life?
Balance maybe the wrong word because
probably there is no balance.
So how are you going to combine them?
How are you going to have a satisfying
family life and a satisfying career.
[MUSIC]
Often somebody says,
well my mother is going to come and
take care of the kids while I work.
And I always think okay, have you asked
your mother and often they had not.
So I say, well, the first step of
your plan is to ask your mother.
[LAUGH] Some of them come back the next
session and say, my mother says no thanks,
been there done that, I'm not going to
be taking care of your children.
So it's a chance for people to be real.
And also, with regard to elder care.
Generally, we have very generous
people in the class who say
that what they'll do when their parents or
parent needs care is they'll bring
that parent into their house.
And I say, well, do you know if that's
what your mother or your father or
your mother-in-law wants?
Well, no,
we haven't had that conversation.
Well, have that conversation.
And again, oftentimes,
the parent does not want that.
[MUSIC]
There are still women,
including women who are about to get
an MBA who want to take time out.
Who don't want to come back to work.
And often they're the ones
who feel deviant.
Because after all they've got an MBA.
And presumably they went for
that degree because they want to work.
But then they have a child and
they want to take some time off.
So the question of how you take time off,
how much time you take,
and most important what
you do while you're out.
Namely you better keep
your networks up and
you better keep your hand in the business.
So you know what's going on because
if you actually disappear totally for
five years or ten years, for sure.
You're going to have a lot
of trouble coming back.
[MUSIC]
It's really a family decision
because if she leaves the workforce,
unless your family is
independently wealthy,
there's going to be a lot more
pressure on you, the man.
So you should know that, and you and
she should talk about this, and
how long is she going to be out for, and
what's she going to do to keep
her finger in it while she's out?
And maybe the two of you want to have
a different conversation which is not,
when should she leave and
how she should come back.
But maybe you want to talk about
what the two of you can do so
that you can both stay in.
Perhaps you're going to put
more money into hiring a nanny.
Or you're going to make it worthwhile for
your mother-in-law to
play a bigger role here.
Maybe your wife can work part time.
Maybe you can both work part time.
Anyway we're trying to increase the number
of options that people have and make
it a family decision rather than the woman
just saying this is what I want to do.
[MUSIC]
You can't possibly plan everything out.
You don't know if a child that you
have will be a special needs child,
in which case all of your planning is for
not.
Because that child is
going to take precedence,
your decisions are all going to be
about how to help that child and
planning, or there's a death of a spouse,
in which case everything is different.
Or even a divorce that
you didn't see coming.
So I think planning is a very good thing,
but
everybody should understand that,
what's the old saying?
Man plans and God laughs.
You just can't possibly
plan out everything.
[MUSIC]
What are you going to do in
the place where you work?
In a large corporation,
in a small startup, what are you going to
do personally to help other people
to balance work and family?
How are you going to change
policies about family leave?
What are you going to do about
childcare for your employees and
the people you manage?
I remember one guy saying
you know I told her
when she comes back she doesn't
have to have her old job back,
she can be in a much easier
job with less travel.
And in general there's at least one women
student in a class raised their hand and
said I don't want that.
When I come back I want to be just
treated the way I was before.
I want the travel.
I want the promotions.
And so men and women get to see that
not everybody has the same view here.
Some women want to come back and
take a slower role for a while,
and some don't and the only way to know
this is to actually have a face to face
conversation [LAUGH] with the employee,
when she's ready to come back.
What is it that you see for yourself.
And the other thing they learn is that
what you say when you're pregnant and
you've never had a child before, may be
different from what you say when you have
had the child, particularly if the child
has a problem of one sort or another.
And so again, people see that and
they learn from each other.
They see what a wide variety
of experiences people have.
[MUSIC]